Are you sure this is the right guy's house? I mean, seriously, I do not want to show up
uninvited with a backpack full of ASMR tools in its wrong place. It just seems all too
convenient. I know I shouldn't be so skeptical, but this seems all too perfect. We get contacted
about being able to have new model outfits for the small, small price of showing up to
their house and jingling them for an hour. Doesn't that seem suss to you? You know, normally
I'm called the naive one, but this... Do you want a new outfit for your V2 remodel or not?
It's not like we can't take him on anyways, it's 2v1. We're gonna beat him up with what my feet...
Hello there, dear producer. Are you okay if I call you that? It's kind of a cute nickname.
I'm, well, strongy, and this is said, of course, but you already knew that because you requested
us specifically out of, well, all the Vtubers that do ASMR somehow. Sorry, I'll try and focus. It's just,
it's our first time doing something like this. Yes, I brought everything, actually.
It's all in my bag, right here. Are you wanting to do this in a living room? I suppose it's fine
if you want to be comfortable on your bed, so we don't mind. Just lead us in line down and we'll
see what we can do. You didn't exactly specify what you were looking for in the email, so we
can just take it tingle by tingle. Oh, you want us both to do it at the same time? Of course.
Let me go to one side of you on the bed and strongy'll go to the other side, alright?
Are you comfortable? Well, I guess it goes without saying. If you fall asleep, we'll just leave
you be. Of course, we do expect that outfit money when you wake up. We do know where you'll live
after all. Strongy, excuse her. She just doesn't understand this level of exchange.
When an opportunity like this comes around, it's very silly to not reach out your hand and take it.
The kindness of people like yourself allows us to continue to do what we love.
Now, please, enough of keeping you away. Time for you to be taken away to Tingaland, huh?
Since we both have our hands free, we'll start slowly and then layer more and more until you've
passed out, alright? Don't worry, you're in our very capable hands. Thank you again for this
opportunity, producer. Thank you, producer, for this. Seriously. Please, just let me return the favor
in any way I can.
Thank you.